november 3rd election day in america is
edging ever closer
some are not just nervous about the
results but nervous about the real
potential for
violence in the streets over the course
of the past few months
amid the pandemic tensions have been at
boiling point and at some points even
boiling over
violence has taken place at political
rallies
[Music]
last weekend it was boston that was the
site of scuffles between trump
supporters and left-wing activists
videos like this are becoming more and
more common across america
the country is becoming more and more
polarized
you have this witch's brew that really
hasn't happened in america's history
and if it has it's been decades if not
centuries
right wing militias and antifa are both
heavily armed and both
walking the streets freely in american
[Music]
cities
gun sales are record high now the year
isn't even over yet but already the fbi
has announced that 2020
is the record year for the number of fbi
background checks for gun purchases
tensions are being ratcheted up by both
candidates who are both suggesting that
the other guy
is rigging the vote my single greatest
concern
this president's going to try to steal
this election it's democrats
they're going gonna they're trying to
rig this election
will the elections have a quick result
that is accepted by everyone
or will it be contested with both
candidates having supporters that are
armed and ready for battle
things could explode very quickly